so
larry elder larry elder governor state
of california yes what are your thoughts
i'm sick i'm freaking excited tell us
why tell us why because
larry elders are no uh i think
he's from south central or compton
conservative pull-up is a problem it's
just this guy is just
he he doesn't he doesn't care to offend
you if he offends you he doesn't care
he believes in american values he's
pro-america he's pro
freedom he's watching you know he talks
about by the way he's been a radio taco
show for like
20 or 30 years he's consistent this is
not he's not switched sides in the past
20 or 30 years
he has a lot of credibility people know
who he is by the way he has a 62 percent
approval rate in california right now
62 62 percent so are you sure about that
they did a poll they didn't pull up the
62 percent they did
larry elder uh it was a 62 percent
approval uh
rating they did a california yeah they
did an approval uh put the number 62
next to it that's 62.
keep going yeah so so you're excited
about him because
oh let me see there's there's there was
a poll that they did they
i wouldn't be surprised if they brought
it down so what's happening in
california
i'm not paying as much attention as i
should is it going to be like a runoff
is it gonna be ranking choices voting
it's it's uh
um it's uh it's a um recall
so on september or september the ballots
go in
but so is it just is it is it ranked
choice is it 30 people whoever gets the
most votes yeah
it's the same thing like any other like
any other run so it's just whoever
whoever can
generate the most are there going to be
mail in ballots as well or
we don't know that's going to be the
question okay we don't know that but
they did a poll on it
he he i don't know maybe they're brought
up by the way you know
right even though there's so ready for
this you know what
kailyn jenner's approval rating was uh
uh 14
one four she was the second one in the
reigning in that poll that they did
she was the second one because if you
take a larry elder out yeah
according to the obviously you can
always 100 go off of them she'd be the
governor of california
wow she and then like number three was
like six percent
and then two percent it was insane yeah
that's right i guess the question is
california actually voting for a
republican
bro well i'm people are tired i know a
lot of
i know a lot of democrats that are tired
that are tired of the way things are
going
and they're speaking out if i showed you
my dm right now man of people like bro
you were right we need to get this idiot
out of here we need to vote republican
there's even african-americans at this
point they're like we need to vote
republican we need but we take a break
from the democrats for a while
you know remember uh i don't know if you
ever watch that thing with kat williams
he's like you know we're gonna get a new
presidency can we take a break from
prince can we date a president right
that's what kind of four years right now
can we just date one can we just say
see if it works out can we take a break
can we be single for a while yeah i i
have a comedy bit that i do
that i talk about uh i'm just sick of
debates i don't want any more debates i
want to see like these guys do like the
aggro crag like uh
legends of the hidden temple or
something like that i want to see like
compete against each other
like like old school uh american
gladiators like tell me you want to be
funny
i would not be surprised if they brought
it down no what i'm trying to find out
right now is who are the candidates who
who do they have right now
you can find that it's we got major
williams
you got caitlyn jenner
that guy's not even going to be nowhere
near governor for
many many moons to come exactly that's
the problem oh yeah major williams major
williams yeah major williams so is larry
elder the best chance right now
hell yeah okay oh bro you got to follow
him to know like
it's not even a yes it's a hell yes
larry elder is exactly what california
needs right now
and everybody he's only going to have
one year and then he's got to run again
right
uh i doubt that good question bro i have
no idea oh you know what you're right
you're right you just finished out the
term yes but yeah
so could gavin newsom theoretically bro
yes he could run but he ain't nobody
even
this is this is real so i just decided
let me let me send you this i found a
link
uh that has larry elder leading
everybody including democratic
candidates for recall yep uh let me told
you this to you i told you but i'm
excited for this event
boom california follow the link well uh
while we have some dead air here david
why don't you come and
strum on the sixth string brother we
have we got something david's gonna do
at the end david brace yourself you'll
be all the way at the end so once we
have the biggest crowd you'll come and
perform
ky if you want to pull this out this is
from a few hours ago this is from a few
hours ago
you found the pat you found one it's not
the 62 percent but you found kind of
validates
yeah what you're saying kai if you can
pull this up so this is from fox san
diego which is not fox news
it's not fox news people don't confuse
don't don't confuse the three
differences
larry elder leads race to replace
newsome in recall election new poll
reveals go a little lower
it's a dope looking shirt and then he
just announced this how long ago a week
two weeks ago
just a week ago so go over here okay
which candidate would you vote for to
replace gavin newsom if he's recalled
larry elder 16
john cox six percent kevin faulconer
six percent kevin kiley four percent
kately jenner four percent meet kevin
two percent
someone else eight percent undecided 53
60 kevin is the third kevin he's
doubling everybody pat
it's a little bit of everybody pushing
each other and we're going to get them
in office
telling you i'm campaigning for the
other way this exclusive new statewide
poll with a statewide poll of more than
a thousand registered voters
which has a margin of error points minus
point two wow
it has a margin of error of plus minus
two point nine percent
he would still he would still beat him
ask respondents who they would vote for
the governor some elder let the pack
with sixteen percent john cos coming up
from six percent majority
don't go a little lower go a little
lower to see what's on the bottom here
there it is with uh okay
the radio is leveraging which california
ballot earlier found suit members
300 pages tax returns across canada but
elders not including
well i mean there you go we're going to
see what's going to happen in the state
of california well they might open
pat when they did that poll that i'm
telling you about immediately after they
took him off the ballot because he never
when he submitted his uh taxes there was
a discrepancy not in his taxes there was
just a discrepancy in the way he
submitted them
and they didn't want to let him run they
said oh no no you you did it wrong we're
not going to let you
of course no well no look at that
well they're scared of them they know
what he's going to do
makes it illegal for guys name scroll
back down kai
scroll back down here's actually the
most interesting part of the poll other
than larry elder
there's more than 50 percent that are
still undecided they're
they're open we're gonna flip them you
know so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye